here's a lady right here with a question
oh wait for me yeah hey Theo and Chris I
hope you're both doing well so my
question is for both of you
I know Chris has mentioned he's played
high school and college basketball so if
you had a pickup game of just sand
comedians who would be your starting
five and why thanks for everything
great well first let me go first um well
I lose by letting you go first go ahead
you go first then okay I'm gonna first
so this is a great question by the way
it is a great we gotta do like the
playground
Theo gets a pick then on the snake Chris
- Chris gets two and then Theo gets time
we'll do it like that go ahead you go
first deal um years ago they tried is
this uh who's your first pick
using this live hold on my first pick uh
I need a basketball player
I need somebody you know I'm honestly
I'm thinking urban out of the gate I'm
trying to see who's out there that's a
good player that maybe used to play
you're already taken I'm gonna go with
um all right I'm gonna go with my boy
I'll go with Brendan Schaub I'll put him
down an apprentice shop yeah I was
thinking - I want to only pick black
guys so I'm gonna start off with Andrew
Schultz and then no mom no fashion in
the paint no you could do more than
three seconds of fashion in the paint
you're out so I'm gonna take Andrew
Schultz as my as my first black eye and
then second I'm gonna take second I'm
gonna take I'll take Dave Chappelle Wow
yeah does he who I don't know but it's
just nice to have two black legends on
your squad respect respect yeah I'm
gonna go with
ah this is so tough even though I have
this wall right here to help i'ma go
with gimme you get two mm-hmm you take
two okay then I'm gonna go with I'll go
with Andrew Santino mmm
nice yeah one more right yep and I'm
gonna go with um I'll probably roll with
Leslie Jones nice that's a nice pick
that's defense that's defense so now
I've picked my final two mm-hmm okay so
my final two I'll say I will go with my
second pick I'd like to go with Eric
Griffin nice yes he's tall he can coach
when he yeah yeah well no I got it I got
a pick for who my coach is gonna be okay
um and then for the fifth my final I'd
like to round it out I'll round it out
with Bill burr Wow wrap it up with bill
bird just a tough Boston guy that you
know will miss one shot start punching
people in the face cause a fight I like
that
okay I wanted like a scrappy white dude
or is that a Hilbert respect man I'm
gonna roll then I need a little bit of
out so I'm gonna need a shooter from the
outside so I'm gonna go with I'm gonna
go with give me uh give me Sebastian
I'll take Sebastian minutes nice Chicago
he stays in shape yeah and I could see
him it might be really hilarious to
watch but I could see him smile shooting
a three-pointer yeah yeah yeah yeah in
those pants and I can see him jumping
when he does it he needs to jump yeah
you got one more pick alright I got one
more pick then I need I'm gonna need a
little bit more help down in the paint
I'm gonna go with somebody long I'm
gonna go with Chris Porter nice Chris
Porter that's a good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches wall
ah